hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot
gameplay for the past few days we've
been diving deep into XCOM twos new war
of the Chosin expansion experiencing
everything the game's revamp has changed
and if our time with it so far is any
indication or of the chosen changes a
lot in the clip you're watching you can
check out all three new resistance units
you'll have access to from the psionic
Blade wielding Templar to the stealthy
glass cannon Reapers to the walking
one-person armies that we know as the
skirmishers you also get to watch this
battle that shows an assassin one of
three new persistent bosses add in the
expansion and the lost or zombie-like
enemies that swarm both you and your
alien enemies you'll also get to see a
few minor changes such as the mental
effects battle can take on different
soldiers and how relationship bonds can
help you out in the middle of a
firefight
we'll have war of the chosen gameplay
going up on game spots throughout the
week but in the meantime be sure to LIKE
comment and subscribe and watch our
weekly live show the lobby on Wednesday
at 11 a.m. PST where we're taking an
even deeper look at war of the chosen
myriad changes see you then
perhaps you should take further time to
reflect Templar or you find yourself
about matched humans do share an
admirable sense of loyalty even in the
face of certain good copy
moving on target
get up and get back out there
I move
I go where I'm needed
power protection
we will fight together
moving out
placing the weapon
[Music]
I'm on my way
some get some
beyond deception
creatures
remember they are not victims my
religion dry
[Music]
servos engaged
[Music]
yeah I am almost out of ammunition
permanent covering now I am on watch
stands relatively easy for this very
purpose now go
[Music]
my
you will join your compatriots soon
enough
that is not good
which you have allowed their capture
what do you think your soldier will
share with me
given their fragile condition
moving on TARDIS
darkness is my domain
I go where I'm needed you will never
hide from me
[Music]
good to go
in the way
just a moment
[Music]
[Music]
wash away - solace launderettes have
even worse off in the human
do I fight many what dies today
[Music]
moving as ordered
advancing
[Music]
I need to help you
overwatch right already
that's weapon there's a mark of another
where did you find it
you know resupply
you